all right a new bill just passed by the
house could mean big changes for the
u.s. retirement system and your wallet
the legislation would allow more small
businesses to offer retirement plans
help people contribute to their
retirement while paying off student
loans and let parents use retirement
money to help with childcare CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here with how it could affect you Jill
good morning this is the biggest change
to retirement in about a decade is that
right yes since 2006 and there are so
much in this bill in addition to the
things you just listed for retirees
right now you have to start pulling
money out of your retirement account at
age 70 and a half this bill would
increase that to age 72 it would allow
seniors to put more money in their
retirement plans right now you can't put
money into an IRA after age 70 and a
half this bill says no keep working put
money away it also does help people who
are trying to juggle their student loans
families could tap their 529 plans pay
up to ten thousand dollars a year down
on their student loans talked about how
small businesses can band together these
are such important ways to help get more
people on the road to a retirement plan
important since most of us knock on what
hopefully will live a lot longer that's
right we hope to so is there anything in
the bill that will help pay for the
changes well what's interesting is the
bill would contemplate the the payment
for this by changing the rules about
inheriting a retirement account now if
you're a spouse there's never a rule
about what you have to do with that you
get the money from your spouse you can
take that out over a long period of time
right now under this rule it would say
if you inherit an IRA or a retirement
account and you're not the spouse you
would have to take money out of that
plan within ten years that's how the
government would then tax that money at
whatever your income tax bracket is at
the time Jill this bill passed by a huge
majority in the house is it going to
pass in the Senate it looks like it's
going to pass in the Senate a few
details to iron out and I think the
president then goes to sign this Jill
Schlesinger always good to have you at
the table